all right hey well hey what's going on
it's bill burr and it's time for a very
special edition of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast you know whenever I have
a guest I always try to make sure that
it's gonna be somebody special and I
don't know how to top this one as far as
influence on why the hell I'm sitting
here how I even know how to write a joke
or where the hello you know all these
towns in Massachusetts in New Hampshire
are please welcome Boston comedy legend
Don Gavin very nice to be here bill yes
thank you for calling me special you
were here to promote you have a new they
call it an album an audio digital audio
download available Don Gavin live with a
Manhattan live with the Manhattan with
the Manhattan very important not from
Manhattan it's correct okay with a man
with the Manhattan which is available
right now on Sirius and Pandora and then
Friday of this week it's going to be
available everywhere iTunes Spotify any
stream you can find strawberries Rhema
great go whatever yeah absolutely so
whoa what's going on man hey I don't
think I've ever run into you out here in
LA that's because I haven't been out
here for quite a while I was last time
you were out here oh man did some
commercials maybe in the two thousand
two or three years ago okay and I get
eight $300 jaywalking tickets so I
didn't come back which I haven't paid by
the way I don't know oh there's a
warrant out for you I know what the
statute is where were you where were you
jaywalking ah right down and it right
down in the Hollywood is I up right near
with their comedy stories down that way
okay and they call out the copper
actually pulled me he says do you I am
you know what I'm pulling you over I go
well you're not pulling me over I'm I'm
walking all right and I said I thought
this only happened in the movies 300 300
300 father and I had to go in are
supposed to be doing this commercial you
can he said I don't believe you because
I dressed in sweatpants and looked like
a bum riots which is normal garb and he
he came in the studio with me to check
to see if Elvis [ __ ] for real like
because they had no ID on me
so I think he wanted to arrest me Oh cuz
you didn't have an idea cuz I was
thinking why does he keep waiting to
give a [ __ ] what you do I don't know but
he wanted his three hundred dollars at
some point which they haven't gotten so
they you ever watch those videos online
when those people actually know their
rights and they just start going at the
cop I would still be nervous to do that
like no I'm not required to give you an
idea I'm not in a car yeah I'm sure I'm
a citizen I'm sure they'd say well then
we'll just hold you on to you produce
this of that yeah I'm got the time for
that no I don't think I did the savvy to
do it I don't have that law background
yeah how did the how did the get-go the
commercial shoot I didn't get Larry do
you name it did they make you fly
yourself out here I got I was already
out here for a while oh you were I
rented to the to the west coast a few
times I lived in students sitting up for
that's what I was living at that time I
believe yeah oh you did okay I actually
took me the longest time to like it out
here yeah but now I know it's home I
like it I I do definitely get nervous
with the whole it's a city that does
that exist but shouldn't exist mm-hmm
you know and yeah sometimes I get that
gets to me is as far as like you know
the dollar collapsing and and and you
know global warming I'm kind of like but
then the other side of me is like well
it'll be over quick I mean you guys back
east you got all those lakes and [ __ ]
you can sit there and fill up your can
tea but I'm gonna be [ __ ] out here but
with many other people though you won't
be alone yeah I think it'll be all of us
self-involved people tweeting about how
we're dying but I tell me about this
album where did you where did you record
and do it I just it's such a thrill I
gotta say again to have you on here like
I appreciate you hours and hours and
hours and hours that I've watched you do
stand-up we've all different kinds do
you remember that time I showed up super
late yes you think I was telling some
friends about oh my god no no I'll tell
you listen as this one
yes sir mr. burr comes in we were
working at a in New Hampshire a place
that was man yeah it was that I think
boys Johnathan's I think the
neighborhood anyways so it never stays a
two-man show and in those days bill was
was the opening act and I'm the closer
and so the opening act bill somehow
comes
quite late I was at least 90 minutes and
so now I its the deal is I'm gonna have
to go in first you're gonna second you
came through the door but you you had me
out for them handed me off at the pass
instead of instead of I being apologetic
he said I don't want you in my face
leave me alone
you wouldn't believe the traffic good
and you went on and on I said yeah I
wouldn't believe the traffic that's why
I came about three hours early and then
afterward you apologize I remember I was
so [ __ ] pissed and then also but I
was so scared
yes yes I was like you were in Timmons
gonna call my clack and then that's
gonna be I'm gonna be out of kegels and
then Mike
he has everybody's all the big guys ears
Lenny Sweeney all it noxee rest his soul
Tony and all of them and I was just like
I am just gonna I just I just what
however long I've been working too much
two and a half years at work down the
tubes feel I got a move build birds
career goes down before it begins
yes that's what I was worried about but
you were I maybe was sitting at the bar
it was morning yet you didn't sit in all
right you didn't say anything you just
were looking at me as I was spewing all
this [ __ ] out
yeah and then I just sort of ran out of
steam and you were just looking at me I
just went I'm sorry man I I can't and
you just went sorry it's just sit down
we're gonna figure this out
that was I had two fuck-ups like that
really I know when when I pulled up to
my Clark's giggles in Saugus and I I
want to say I was with Tony V and we
thought it was an 8:30 show we got there
like 10 past 8:00 and Mike is standing
outside the club we don't know why so
hey Mike how's it going and heating his
head he's like these [ __ ] [ __ ]
are showing up ten minutes late and
comes strolling in yeah like that 20
minutes early because that was our vibe
and he goes listen pal you know I don't
mind if you're gonna be like oh you know
just gotta give me a call - that was
just like yeah man if I'm ever late yeah
I'll give you a call and we like went
back and forth like a bad sitcom not
understanding each other then he goes
pal the show supposed to start ten
minutes ago and I was like yeah you guys
will also [ __ ] intimidate you know
what I mean cuz you guys had like you
would like the generation before me oh
you were even angrier than my generation
so you actually scared my lunatic
generation so when you made a live with
the Manhattan which by the way is that
your drink
might be
yes you're fortunate I have something
else after dinner but yeah so no it's
kind of a kind of an old person to drink
which I am kind of an older person but I
will try stick with tradition yeah
classy guy Manhattan you could be
absolutely shit-faced but you got slacks
on you drinking notes you're fine it
looks like it I don't yeah hasn't got a
pink straw in it our upcoming loss I
always always say just sort of a
straight like when I was a beer guy
first and then I want then I switched to
like Bourbons and I kind of just went
that on the rocks are just straight so
educate me here what is what is it is
that is a it's a Canadian whisky with a
little bit of a little bit of bitters
just tiny bit of bitters and a nice
cherry in it and sweet vermouth
that's it oh god that sounds delicious
yes they can own rather easy at least
from boat let me just because I been
laying off the booze for a little bit so
I like to live vicariously through
people so you have this Manhattan before
dinner
yes which by the way that's that's
that's an America that should come back
yes you know aperitif yeah after you
well what what's what you go to drink
dawn wants a buzz Oh Don doesn't really
know say one of buzz but my go-to drink
is a lot of vodka with a hint of Kahlua
which would be a tan Russian not a black
behind Thanh Thao you go like up and I
usually put those in a gallon barrels
and that's how I drink a lot of ice make
sure you guys take some quarter that
gallon yeah you do I'm gonna make sure
that yeah you're properly lubricated you
know absolutely yeah that's the deal
what is this where did where did you
record this album we did it actually at
the Portland comedy connection and
you've important the car mechanics if we
did this thing and after I did it six
months later the place closed so that's
how effective I was up at that point oh
no that's not there anymore that finally
closed yeah well it was on a pier you
just remember that was yelling a pod and
finally somebody wanted to dinner yes I
actually fell halfway through the pier
not all the way into the water right the
place wasn't following a fire a little
spot but but the comedy there was a
terrific yeah remember the original one
oh yeah
the original one was was more downtown
Portland and I remember doing spots up
there for I swear to God I felt like
half a year and we would be like what
the [ __ ] is that smell and they found
out a rat had died and it was like it
wasn't right above you as a comic it was
like off to the right on that beam the
thing just just I don't had a heart
attack or something it just died it
didn't fall and it just laid there and
nobody could close enough to the ocean
you thought it [ __ ] low tide let you
know what's going on here the other had
a dead rat up there yeah so now I think
it's a restaurant or maybe it's a yeah I
rise they don't know motors but I did
buy any clothes now well of all the
places you've done your all-time
favorite room to do stand-up and just go
up where you just knew you were gonna
you were gonna murder wow that's a good
question I like the smaller intimate
rooms which is with my fame that's that
super rooms that I work right your
wheelhouse you do these big large
auditoriums to me that's showing off so
I keep it full of myself I like to keep
my cross down and usually like double
figures you know there's an air of
mystery about you when you work
yessum it's a mystery all right that's
why we're trying to get this album both
so maybe I'm not a mystery idea I used
to see the quotes all the time this I
was Boston and comedies best-kept secret
I'm going to it can we change that about
possible people start talking about well
that's why you're doing the podcast here
correct you know it's a great one to
Lizzie the old comedy the original
comedy come on Warren Street that was
like I feel like those places well the
audience would you could actually reach
out and touch the audience or was that
it was that close I actually have the
first time I ever videotape myself I
have it on no I won't be showing this
anywhere I have a VHS tape of me yeah at
the at the comedy connection I've been
doing comedy it was 1993 so I've been
doing it for one year was the first time
my parents came to see me uh-huh and I
went up and I did five minutes and I
killed thank God and I still have that
thing and I think it took me 10 years
before I even showed it to my wife
like oh my god you're a little boy big
you know the big red afro right
stupid early 90s lime green shirt it was
hilarious that was like the only show in
town therefore in Boston for years and
it was usually decent yeah you know the
crowds were good although I didn't
wasn't a one time was working with Lenny
Clarke and some woman gets trashed and
threw an ashtray a big glass ass trailer
go in those days everybody was smoking
right Adam and he duck and the thing
smashed against the wall broke into
pieces and Len he goes you got to be
quick on your feet if you're a comedian
and then so my friend was the bouncer
every time he goes over okay who did
that and so finally they point out to
the girl and he goes man he goes okay
who's the boyfriend the boys my senses I
gotta knock somebody else you know he
knocked up the guy like I need the broad
but I can knock out the guy I I feel
like those stories only exists like in a
few cities during a certain time like
even that like that craziness of that
story that was gone by the time I came
up were a little more civilized well it
would be like yeah the logic of that
would not have would not have passed I
just was talking to Jay Leno right and
he was telling a story about some guy
while he was onstage you heard this guy
you know yell out in pain and he found
out afterwards the guy was talking and
the bouncer stabbed him in the leg like
hey guy was sitting down he just see
just just right in his thigh that guy
screamed and he [ __ ] threw him out
and then years later when Jay made it he
he called him up right going hey man
remember i iiked you up that one time
like call him up i don't look him for a
favor or something like that and james
like i didn't ask you to stab somebody
while I was onstage I mean I could I
could have just had a funny retort I had
a similar one I'm doing gonna be doing
the evening The Improv the next day so
I'm just going over my set at Knicks
boss and that's one of the clubs I
started in in Boston and so I'm just um
I said and sometimes yeah one in Hecht
and I said yeah what I'm finished corner
and finished kind of in turn a ting they
might do more than talk so instead he
rushes the stage with his friend I'm
distracted and I get hit in the back of
her head by this big steel chair so
there's an all-out brawl
everything the cops get involved people
rolling around knives were taken out
so anyways I'm on the blood thinner I'm
getting kicked by three people I turned
my assailant on top and they kicked the
[ __ ] out of him but you're thinking it
was me so then we're leaving and the
other guy the first guy that was saddled
a whole thing he's behind a cop going
hey you know like he got away with it
so I took a shot at him the club stepped
between us and I hit the cop right in
the face I got arrested at my own show I
had to spend the night in jail
I had a black guy that I should I go
ahead and go on evening improv the next
book and I will L keep on Elton John
classes so people thought that was a
joke and it wasn't because my it was
black yeah I thought you were no
Hollywood yeah but I got arrested at my
own show and so they leave me out in
cuffs and the people going that's a
headliner that's the guy at the end what
how come he's getting arrested yeah so
that was a deal but I hit the cop but
you know what is the the the just a lack
of like cameras so you sort of settled a
lot of [ __ ] amongst yourself like now
there would have been video that oh yeah
it would be video of you hitting the car
and the fact that the guy came up on it
and so the story goes so we go to the we
go to the jail and and somebody's drunk
out of their ass in the jail and people
yelling at occur and all this kind of
stuff second can you sleep so I'm
exhausted but I'm so I have to go to I
have to go to court like two months
later but the assailants these two guys
came in there any an orange two
jumpsuits because they've been arrested
three or four times since they know
similar to your story about four years
later a guy comes up to me goes you
remember me I'm the guy they hit you
with the chair and like I think he
wanted me to compliment him yeah like
you went to high school to go when did
you find like that like because when I
started that we just hear all of these
crazy stories when did it it start to
you know slow down where it became just
more established and more so because it
started to ding ho Chinese restaurant
and nobody went in there that was called
the Springfield Street saloon that was
the ding whole world it became infamous
and but the people did you know there
wasn't such a thing a comedy there was a
train for us from barely surviving and
and there was the people at the Bob well
we couldn't throw them out so they'd
stay there and they'd be turned around
and shut the [ __ ] up you know to the
comedian's because they were
we were bothering there yeah they're
drinking for the day so finally we had
to weed them out like that but there
were a lot of fisticuffs simple thing
and then it became more is that why
noble is that why all you guys are so
big I was thought there was like a
height requirement for the first wave of
Boston comes you Sweeney leery all you
guys are like 6-1 6-2 6-3 Lenny yeah DJ
has it was you Santa L he's a big guy I
just was sitting there going like well
no wonder these guys were able to
establish the scene I always felt like
there was a group of people like 510 and
below that tried like the early
seventies and got destroyed kind of like
with the Red Sox do you remember the Red
Sox actually this is their second mascot
the first mascot they had was sometime
in the 70s was called the Fenway freak
and it lasted like three games and just
got peddled you got the [ __ ] kicked out
of him the guy's like [ __ ] that man you
put the goddamn head on you walk out
there I'm not doing it anymore I always
wanted like like whenever I would do
like comics come home right and Leary
would be there and there's always a
couple of you guys there but I always
still feel like a little kid looking up
but you guys going like T everybody and
then Patrice when he came along right he
was like he was like the only guy from
our generation that was like like your
guy's height yeah we said when the thing
was you had to be fast on your feet and
perhaps whether you wit and fast with
your hands yeah and there were a number
of the hands thing that came in hey can
you tell the story I don't know I think
it was attributed to you the time you
had that gig way out in western mass and
you showed up and there was no stage oh
yeah I go to this thing it's good so no
so outdoor concert after concert it was
gonna be a nice venue and people sitting
on up against trees and lying on the
grass and and as a the big this stage
was set up but they're barely and they
were still kind of setting things up the
band that was supposed to come and there
was a name band I can't remember now it
was supposed to come in later and so the
guy says to me oh you ready to go wanna
go on what you ever got the state's put
up and he says he said no that's fine
what I can do is say I have a megaphone
I'll give you the megaphone and just go
over like to that tree with the people
our and do a couple of jokes and then go
over here to this tree and I'm going
this guy's serious yeah so I said oh
sure I can
do that I said but I got to go to my car
to get my puppets first so I went oh my
god and he always saw him after that he
didn't even see but I drove away it was
the end of that and then but I went
quick enough so the place said I was
high and collected my money in cash
before they found out that I didn't show
oh my god
I got to get my puppets and to this day
I have the guy's megaphone what I love
about that story that never dawned on me
to do that the amount of times that I
should have said oh yeah let me go back
to the car get my props yeah I got a
sport coat I'll be right back and just
left yeah god I always start like your
generation 2 had like this this thing
that when like someone was trying to
[ __ ] you on a gig you aren't in some way
or another you got him back like I mean
Mike Donovan used to always tell me when
he would do a bad gig he would take all
the money and buy himself something like
a VCR or a stereo or something and that
would be his [ __ ] you really I don't
even know I don't know if that makes
sense but that was that's what he said
he goes I would just go out and go by
myself because [ __ ] those people I'm
gonna get something nice out of this and
that never dawned on me to do that I
mean Patrice was the first one to ever
tell me like bill you can say no to
these things I was so into the whole
thing like I'm a comic coming up I got
to pay my dues I got to pay my dues this
there is that tipping point where you
have to put a value on what it is that
you're doing and it's just like if
you're not even gonna I started to say
at college gigs when they said we don't
have a microphone is that gonna be a
problem I was like have you ever watched
a late-night talk show have you ever
seen a comedian go out without a
microphone no microphone I'm on hell or
someone for a lumber companies and 600
people and I get there and you know
they're all seated everybody's dressed
up and the guy said the same thing
we don't wear over mic but is that a
problem no 600 people you can be
[ __ ] me yeah this is the problem you
know yeah every time I did college kick
it was always like there was always like
you know we have a mic that was always a
guy and the guy wasn't the guy with the
key it's in the closet
he's not here yeah we feel if we make a
semicircle around you that you call
you're gonna do the college's you have
to do those just call them cheese's
where'd you go into the cafeteria and do
like time management material
to kids that are eating they couldn't
give a [ __ ] less that you were even on
planet you know and they call them
teasers yeah you have to do ten minutes
of you know and then you were gonna be
and he'll be appearing for four hours
from now I'm like thank people go hell
is this guy just get the humiliation of
a city when I did Memphis they the only
place that I've ever worked that they
positively hated me they hated me they I
was heckled before I got on stage before
they introduced me and i'm getting
heckled by over there and to do
something from boston this whole take
yankee thing and whatever and it was
horrific
so I go and try to do a good thing and
they had a clock and it's always this
way sometimes for community they'll have
a clock to give you the time but just
type of one of those old-fashioned bells
our clocks like from Back to the Future
that big you know and I could see it
progressing and I'm supposed to do 45
minutes a I'm looking up I said man I
gotta be close to finish a look up but
I've done 18 minutes I'm going oh this
is about 45 minutes of material well
that to a little speedy and kept going
baby I'm in bed till I finish the thing
so well okay tomorrow I'm gonna make up
for it so I went and went to Elvis's you
know where this is he's buried and you
know the house and I said I'll do some
local joke so I go there when I get to
the office place it's cordoned off if
you've ever been there Grayson yeah okay
but really yeah actually kind of look
like house of a were kind of with them
but it's like velvet walls and so I'm I
looked right and it's cordoned off you
know like like at a funeral type of
stuff and so I'm going wow I can't
believe it in the people go Shh be quiet
don't respect for the dead ago he died
like 25 years ago so so so like I do the
show and I go up that night I do some
nice things I think I'm getting they
hate me they hate me a girl and I'm
going this is this is work so that I
went and give my [ __ ] stuff about Elvis
and made sure that they hated me I'm
going I said he's buried in his backyard
I said come on come from we sort of that
if you had like a sparrow or goldfish
you do that next week they get a [ __ ]
shoe box big enough for that fat prick
and so I didn't endear myself at all
then I went tables table i heckled each
table and then i get back in stage look
at that giant clock and i still have 15
more minutes to do so
the story the next night nobody nobody
comes in hey Leo it's lousy weather
there's like he said we would need a
show unless there's 20 people so there's
16 people there I go outside 2 cars pull
up I can go out and roll out anyone who
I said I said sorry plumbing problem
again the show was called off now the 16
people inside but if they had come in I
was gonna have to do a show so I sent
away four or five guys that Peyton
didn't have to do it haven't been back
in Memphis I just I don't know I just
love the survival instinct of that to
just like to not just I would just stand
there and take it you know we didn't
have teasers at the college's you
actually had it we had no nurse you had
to do the whole your whole act that's
horrible - yeah well we think teasers
even worse because people who are
thinking of going to the show then see
you in the worst possible light whether
mean whether eating peanut butter jelly
sandwich yeah those things were always
we're always horrible so I'm so exciting
this damn thing the second I get out of
here live with a Manhattan Don Gavin
available now on Sirius and Pandora and
Friday this week which will be Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday the 24th
everywhere I I Tunes Spotify etc all of
that type of stuff so the good point is
that the virtual comedy Network a new
network of comedy with Jim Serpico he is
the guy that kind of discovered I
rediscovered this particular thing so
now instead of I mean when I used to
sell these I only saw them at a club it
was almost like I was bootlegging my own
material you like a lot of the back of a
trunk Oh cuz you recorded this in 2011
right and I never went to any further
cuz I'm the worst businessman in the
world so well we actually were smart
because you retained ownership of the
thing which is the place I was told that
was mine I didn't I did that by mistake
so that was cool ya know I've ever seen
this guy played in the band he said
you're better to own a hundred percent
of something and sell 20,000 copies but
then did not own any of it and and sell
twenty million because you're gonna make
more money because that's how that's how
bad you get you get you just get [ __ ]
that's why we started all things comedy
yeah who's basically to try to get
comedians together to help each other so
we could maintain ownership of our stuff
because they just they and you would
tell me this is a kind of a co-op type
thing yeah that now moved on to like you
know we sold a couple of
shows we've produced a bunch of stand-up
specials and you know we can maybe
produce a movie here coming up and we
just we just keep expanding what it is
that we do and we just make sure that we
try to protect the the artists for once
well cuz you know they always try to
ship a ship you should be a big deal of
for you it should be exposure we're
gonna get you out there though I'm gonna
stay home watch Netflix while checks
come into my mailbox in you you're gonna
be going to [ __ ] you know
Sasuke Chauhan yeah over the holidays
you probably didn't read the entire
contract so that's yeah yeah that's say
that's definitely a tough thing so how
long did you live out here in LA Oh only
about eight months some people said what
do you like about it I said I like the
weather yeah the weather's great was it
you golfer though not do you would call
it that I have been on the course but
you wouldn't want to see it another 19th
or 20th all over the place a plan no I
did the traffic you know just I don't
know I'm an East Coast guy yeah I get
there I um I just moved to Florida
oh you did congratulations yes the
winter finally I fought the winter for
many many years and the winter one
that's awesome yeah that's awesome well
I next time I do
Florida mail I would love to work with
every satiric yeah seriously open for
you this time
how's that all right get me back you'd
be ninety minutes late just started
yelling at me like I did something wrong
that's great you know I heard uh there's
another guy and he's got some weird
stalker so I can't say who another guy
no I'm not gonna say in the podcast he
moved out of there is there a reason all
of you guys as funny as you were that
you stayed in Boston
well I did because I had two kids and
the shows like when that's great so
you're an awesome dad too well I wasn't
an awesome dad I was I was a dad but I
wasn't I wasn't it could be but uh
passable Pat's was right but now we have
the you know I still go on great with my
kids they have a grandson now
seven-year-old Maddox and that's great
well I'm going to see in a couple days
but we were doing at Nick's Boston what
I said we started with one show we were
doing eventually five shows on Saturday
night in one night so I didn't have to
leave so I did I had my own show there
for nine years straight
he took like one week a year that I
wouldn't work this so there was no
incentive and maybe I was lazy and again
not a good businessman so I just stayed
I stayed no but the thing was you did
you created this thing for all of us to
come into and and and now I get the
checks from oh yeah yeah well the the
thing that blew me away was like I don't
know you guys just had like this diss
there was like almost it's like a rule
of like a certain level funny you had to
be or you just got you just got squeezed
out and if anybody stole a joke they
literally got punched out yeah there was
a code this thing was a quote and we
were very zen a phobic I guess that we
didn't like anybody coming in from New
York or LA comic-con has great stories
about that yes and we intentionally try
to blow him you know not just out of the
room but out of the state you know yeah
that they shouldn't be on I dealt with
that I doubt I did that was that after I
left Boston I would go out there and
what would happen was that the the
middle act as we call it the other than
feature we yeah that feature thing
featured to me is the feature film is
the one you want to see yeah yeah you're
a middle you're working your way up so I
would go out there and the middle act
would go on stage and would just be
murdering for the first seven to eight
minutes and I didn't understand anything
he was talking about see this guy's
gonna be down Johansson screen about two
hours already
oh this guy must be from so-and-so
County or he's gonna be hanging out at
this club and you're just in like you're
just sitting there like okay alright
this is the local and then halfway
through it you realize like the poise of
the guy like oh this is the local
reference headliner guy yeah this is the
hardest guy ever because he's gonna do a
show tailor-made for everybody in that
area code and you will feel [ __ ] it
took you know those shows when I was
learning how to follow a guy like that I
should just gone up men's be like I
don't I didn't understand one [ __ ]
thing that guy was talking about and
whose animals and then why do you why is
a sub so good I heard it was a great
place I could have gone to get the
opposite what he did but I would go up
there and just come cuz he would end on
like 11 and then I would come up and try
to start my act at 11 I like that I like
they just taking the opposite that step
of what he did yeah I never thought to
do that
what I thought was yeah yeah I like that
I would go inside yeah yeah I would go
onstage super high-energy and I remember
many nights 1012 minutes into my set out
of breath sweating from telling jokes
hilarious and everybody just seeing how
uncomfortable I was and then I had run
out of energy and my voice would be
blown out and then I had to do like
another like 35 minutes and as you know
when you when you get in that position
nervousness you go faster instead of
slowing down I'll let me hear you you go
for me to get them to break a minute
enter say and so now but not only do
they not like you they're gonna kind of
even understand you at that that's what
I was thinking maybe happen to you in
Memphis because your cadence yes is way
faster than little fast I was told I
talked 70 words a minute
gusts to 180 yes not good depending on
your your temperament yeah maybe by a
libation before or after yes so how long
ago did you move down Florida oh I just
got there okay I mean I'm sleeping in
the floor for two nights and so I'm
looking forward to getting there and
getting away that's incredible I are you
still gonna go back to Boston at all or
do some stay here and there yeah Wow no
I'm that is it I'm not a massive massive
shift in the Boston comedy scene well
know about that but a message no it is
dude it is it is you don't understand
man you're on the Mount Rushmore so like
Wow Boston just became even more sadder
every time I go but you want to see a
familiar face and say yeah Don Donnie
went down to Florida dude he's a [ __ ]
Snowbird they actually had a going-away
product where they went up some of the
communities I'm not making it up when up
and pleaded with me not to move I'm not
sure what they did I don't think that
you because you're you you don't
understand what you meant to us and how
we was always always
Gavin jokes always like Bob Marley would
always be like yeah I was working with
Gavin it was always somebody said
something in the crowd and then your
your response to them yeah I mean I just
all of those all of those places man I
go back to Boston I have like this this
weird thing well I've kind of learned
now I have to go to new places
cuz if I go into the old Knicks and
that's like a friggin - oh I'm just like
I walk up to him like I'm gonna see Dane
I'm see Patrice I'm Sam Bobby yeah you
know gap or Sweeney's gonna be close
and you just walk in and it's just not
you know I mean granted it's [ __ ] 30
years later only one giggles are still
we are you a lot of them yeah come but
all the other ones like look like Nick's
the one that I said that should have
been unplugged many years ago shut the
lights that thing is dying
well now thing I like is said that's
where I started the first time I ever
stepped on stage to do stand-up comedy
was Nick's comedy stop and March 2nd
1992 and the fact that I've almost been
doing this for 28 years coming up and my
the original room still exists that I
started in is pretty cool because I know
everybody else that I know you know
started in some you know way back then I
was I booked it myself - and of course
didn't get paid to book the show like an
idiot I'd find after four or five years
after years later when I you know worked
more in the coming I found out the guys
getting make him like real good money
book and I go oh I never get paid to do
that yeah I was with that [ __ ] to just
you guys also when used to book us on
your shows like if we had a mediocre set
you guys would get pissed I remember
like noxee would get mad yeah he would
take it personally that he felt that
like that he he said even if it was busy
voting for you and if you didn't level
up to where he thought you were no yeah
then the crowd was looking at him like
keV you [ __ ] us like that's how
personal I think I don't think I was
ever comfortable doing oxy show cuz I
was just like I don't want I don't to be
the guy who [ __ ] Kevin Knox over I
don't want to do that and we used to be
being such a control of it like the
headliner like I'd be the Atlanta but I
was also the MC so the reason I did that
is that yeah I say you okay mom first
you did a good job let you do your 15
next guy supposed to 15 but he's dying
after like six minutes I just go up and
grab the mic out of his hand ago yeah
that was so and so boom yeah so I wanted
to be in control
yeah but you're right if it if you
didn't measure up you knew about it
that's for you who do you watch any
stand-up or anything like that or
anybody that's been catching you lately
anybody from Boston or anything like
that
that uh that you watching and you you
see like okay if this person does the
work then they're gonna get some well no
I'm still kind of healthy I give a lot
of cruise ships so I'm kind of out of
touch with the land I guess that's what
it is right I know a couple of people
from boats that are pretty good because
that's know the sea comics
yeah I only did one cruise ever yeah
you're lucky yeah you can get those lame
cakes that's always good yeah I did that
uh well that's so maybe that's why you
down to Florida because you can get you
can go in and out easier yeah there's a
lot of it work down there and thank you
Mindy I know like cruise work coming out
of Boston Harbor beautiful Boston Harbor
the only cruise anything with booze
cruise cruise those used to be a joy to
you know
people be chipped beef before they get
on you know and they that ended the
Amazon one with three people fell fell
off oh yeah and two of them two of them
they got back so did you have to do to
land up on that yeah we were still doing
it they the fact they wanted us to
continue as they as the Coast Guard was
looking for the body so looking for they
found two of the people oh that guy for
real died oh yeah yeah what's a girl but
but yeah so my audience was cut down by
one that was my concern I used to do I
used to do the the prom gigs oh man
those were [ __ ] horrible those were
like I think those might have been the
worst gigs I ever did like there's a lot
of is some footage of me on the Internet
you know with some tough crowds but like
those things were nothing well Paul we
have the he'll gigs the ones that you
don't want to do you know I did I didn't
want the foxy lady which was still
around I didn't want to do it but the
money was actually quite good and when I
didn't believe I did it one night and it
didn't work out but I'm in this dressing
room or normally they headliner stripper
you know how it would be there
so all these nubile girls 18 to 25 they
said oh what a large times we dress in
here is that okay well I'm going with my
notes I go yeah I'm a giver
and so now sexy play it's totally
totally totally naked woman frolic
around getting dressed about getting
undressed I guess and I'm in there with
my notes I looked at my notes the next
day
I've lines just going down from my
penguin come on attention how did the
gig go well I had to do three sets the
first set before the Nance's came out
what pretty good okay then we had some
death then I went up and they couldn't
have given a [ __ ] less than I was
they're just basically you know come on
where were the tips I did take my shirt
off but not successfully only one time I
did stand I think twice I did stand-up
it's dead like titty bars and stuff like
that those are all
yeah the creepier creepy audience or
whatever yeah all right I'm trying to
think of what else I can ask you this
this is I've never gotten to do this all
these years I've known you I've never
been able to just sit down how have you
enjoyed you lived in Boston through this
incredible sports run yeah you know it's
you know it's odd that kids if you think
a kids that are 12 or 13 years old in
that age
well everyone heard this from more than
one source are going I don't believe
this with but we're not even what are we
gonna have a parade this year meaning
that they're not they at the
championship thing occurs at least once
a year yeah once every two years over
there so the four teams stayed all one
within a nine year period I believe you
know and some multiple time so kids top
that age I'm just going you know because
they love to get the day off from school
and nope no there's no parade this year
yeah like they have no idea
and then the old-timers trying to say
well that the you knows how many is it
well it's looking like we got an extra
parade last year that we shouldn't have
got that whole fiasco Oh nuts is that I
don't know how much parade we're gonna
get this year yeah well the parade there
but they should have given our cameras
anyway my thing is I 100% it's a ping
and I think that the Red Sox are gonna
get there's no way that guy did that
there and he didn't do it
oh I think it's been doing all across
the board yeah but my thing is is I have
sympathy for everybody who lost to us
but I don't what the Yankees I start out
I don't because it's just like alright
if we're really gonna be honest about
fairness and that type of thing I don't
think it was fair that the Red Sox and
Yankees could spend 200 million dollars
and have roided-up free agents from
around the league beat the [ __ ] out of
all these other teams that couldn't
afford it and then we just had a luxury
tax a twenty forty sixty eight the [ __ ]
outta ya I mean there was something they
were all it was it's all been kind of
dirty but I have really enjoyed baseball
watching Kansas City get one watching
the Cubs get one in some of these others
I'd love to see Milwaukee get one like
think they got to get out of this they
got to do more of like the NFL where
they have like parity they have to do
[ __ ] like that like that those that
super team thing I think in the NBA it's
great for playoff ratings but it really
ruined the league
and I just wish they would get back to
like you know back in the day like you
know like whatever Ted Williams was a
red sock this guy was a Yankee and blah
blah blah like like way back in the day
how like magic was on the Lakers bird
was the Celtics it wasn't like you know
when the Lakers started getting the
better best of us you know Larry signs
with the Lakers and then starts walking
around oh I got [ __ ] I got five
championships now instead of three
that's that's the part of it that I
don't like you know and I never liked
that luxury tax isn't the moral
Bilborough that we're hearing right now
yeah yeah but and I think then I just I
think it's silly like say let's say if
the well I can't say the Yankees cuz my
hatred is just so blind to them unless
if any other [ __ ] team did that like
if the Dodgers did it to us it was the
other way around
I would still have to be like in the
back of my head gum well you know we
also had you know one hundred eighty
ninety million teams with free agents
and steroid you know [ __ ] athletes
Andrew Steen and all of this [ __ ] and
we've won four titles so do I give a
[ __ ] that I mean Houston Astros can't
afford to spend two hundred million
dollars and buy up the Red Sox and
Yankees guys so they had to do something
else and then do the shuttered around
the world that guy allegedly some guy
had a [ __ ] telescope out there yeah
from 1951 yeah so I mean I know how many
people are like cheating on their wife
for their taxes and [ __ ] and they're
bitching about the [ __ ] ass so you
mentioned the Yankee thing is so funny
in Boston and fearlessness out here
the hatred for before Boston people hate
the Yankees now the Yankee people just
like Boston but the Boston people hate
it I mean you go to again dip they can
be played in the Brewers and you see
half the people wearing a Yankees suck
t-shirt I don't get they're not playing
they're not here
well that's because you know if you're
of a certain age they rub their nose yes
yeah year after year after year after
you and I thought New Yorkers were a
little bit they were kind of babies when
we won in 2009 for and they were just
like like alright you want whatever
we're happy for you guys alright enough
already but we got we got 26 I remember
they admit 26 to 60 shirts so yeah I
thought they were little
you know I just I actually got a kick
out of that going like dude you you're
like 20 ahead of us like you're gonna
you're gonna make this petty [ __ ]
t-shirt I I was just like wow this
really bothers them or doesn't say all
of them because the same way there's a
bunch of Red Sox still fans still
chanting Yankee sucks which I kind of
think is more like the Potvin Sox you
just do it to do it well III don't do
that so I think something like when
traveling on as I do on the ship stuff
you made people to think the same way
about the Patriots they say positive we
hate the Patriots yeah because of this
exist not any other reason just because
of this success you know I was wearing a
patriot logo on one ship and some woman
nice maybe I need one year a woman comes
up she goes yeah yeah yeah yeah Patriot
Act you probably brought with it because
of that [ __ ] Hillary too didn't you
I'm going wow I don't know it well if
you like the Patriots in Garner oh my
god but I thought they were Trump
supporters that big cheer I go wow okay
I don't know how that came in there but
well I'm hoping I don't know I I am like
I'm a die-hard sports fan so I know look
the Brady thing and all that is coming
to in any of it the Bruins are solid
Celtics are solid the Red Sox are gonna
be fun right now to see who you know you
I think you moved away at the wrong time
you might have been their manager there
well no I'd interim manager you want a
manager that's the more savvy with the
media and photography right
I can't imagine like I just want to know
how the whole thing goes down like how
many players are involved how do you
keep your mouth shut
how do you enjoy the championship after
cuz I'll tell you I saw look when L tuve
got interviewed the look on his [ __ ]
face it just looked like like oh man
this guy definitely knew something I
stopped short of believing that they
wore a [ __ ] wire cuz I would think
that you know like how far are we gonna
take this guy's like we're gonna get
caught have a camera out there and you
know how hard is it with texting and all
that [ __ ] that just man and again it
I've been enough flow locker rooms if
everybody if it was being done everybody
knew it wasn't like one only two people
knew about it it was such a secret
you're not keeping the secret I know
that's but that's why I love that Alex
is going to take the phone to guys on
Houston
like they mastermind the whole thing
like Alex came to the Red Sox and he did
it all by himself I mean come on get the
[ __ ] in and even the initial ones though
they were banging a trash Bell I mean
that's pretty that's you know that's
kind of caveman type I'd like to think
that I could I could pick up on that
after a while the stoppie let's go to
the casino we'll have a little card
counting thing and I'll bang on the
trashcan four times any times the
diamond I think I'm gonna pick up on it
anyways Trevor hit me - for now yeah all
right well listen thank you so much for
coming on
hey it's it's Ron I love you to death
dude it's so great to see you and I
gotta make sure I'm gonna find out where
you're gonna be in Florida so I gotta
make sure I look up because I got one
for you there's a theater done I don't
know if it still exists but you know
when you play those are the ones that I
you think yet now yeah I want the don't
exist well there's you know what you
play that game as far as like hey what's
the first concert you ever went to which
by the way what's your first concert for
me it would had been let me see I mean
that the birds possibly oh wow
Ben Morrison was the fan Morrison yeah
yeah alright yeah so my mother's claim
to fame she saw Elvis I looked up the
date it was it was February 21st 1956
coz and she saw saw him in Sarasota
Florida and he did like fight for shows
there like a 2 or 4 o'clock or whatever
and she said there was like 50 people
there and I looked up in the history
that was the day his first single came
out really yeah and she was down there
for like spring break or whatever and
then when she got back to school in
March everyone was talking about him and
then a month later he went on like
Milton Berle and then that was it
you asked me and actually I left the one
out it was at the Boston Tea Party I
don't want to mention here because I
don't remember but the doors you saw the
doors this because that's the same place
the tickets I remember very expensive
one dollar and seventy five cents what
did you think when you saw it was
unbelievable it was just it was you know
it's something surreal because you know
and the the place probably held 280
people like I am I you probably member
working for stitches my paradise
well I opened for particular act there
and they said it was a black
rhythm and blues people and the name of
the guy was Prince oh my god I hoping
for Prince and and they told me to keep
my show clean totally clean because it's
a black so I think it's gonna be some
religious Mormon group coming out it was
Prince yeah oh my god now I'm going down
this rabbit hole
alright when did you first go to a
Patriots game well hey Nickerson Fenway
no I I would I wouldn't know I never
went to the Nickerson but one Sam Fox by
I was a ticket taker there when they
first opened for the stadium and they
didn't they hadn't completed the parking
lot so there were no lines on the
parking lot she just came in you parked
the car wherever there's a night game
against the Giants exhibition game and
the show ended and the game and excuse
me and people get out of that parking
lot at five o'clock in the morning
because think about no lanes to get in
and get out and I was I was in the Air
Force Reserves then I was going to had a
big meeting at eight o'clock the next
morning
but in my trunk I had a huge cooler with
maybe three cases of beer by the end of
the night it's 3:00 in the morning that
beers for $11 a piece which is now would
you pay when you go anyway yeah but I
made a fortune last one first
what Celtics who was playing when the
first time you saw the Celtics because I
saw Larry in those guys I'm like no way
I go back in the 50s I used to go in
with my which we were ever do you would
never do now but I would go in when I
was like 11 years old my brother was 9 I
might have been 10 and eight and we'd go
on the subway a little thing to station
degree what yeah yeah no one would even
think about sending their kids in find
himself to do that and the tickets again
would go but I remember you know the
Bill Sharman Bob Cousy Bill Russell Sam
Jones Casey Jones Jim let's get off who
was my coach in college about so you sat
there and you got to watch rent over and
I might have sat on the fourth corner
almost always I would sit in the second
row because I'd come down from up above
to there the end because nobody used to
go to the games they want championship
ever champion was never sold out yes I
was they were still selling that game in
fact the people that came in 110 Danone
the seats that I had some businessman
this nice guy there was a yes sure these
two people go to take the seats for
myself brother
and he goes and I see these are the
seats he goes no no these guys are here
all the time
find some other seats because over know
these are our seats we just don't come
to the games because find something else
and you Wow he winked at us and went
away so that was you weren't at koozies
last game without ya yelled out we love
ya I have I still have the program still
had the program 50 saw of mine and when
he yelled at all of you couse it was for
initially it sound like a yelling and
people realize that was pretty cool and
then there was of applause yeah that
guy's like Fame he passed away but he
was like a boss tonight I was it was it
was I read this book on Bob Cousy and
Bill Russell that had and I got to learn
all Tommy Heinsohn all these guys like
and that whole run and then how they
would go out and play these exhibition
games to sell sure they went all the way
through New England that if it did be at
its high school gyms and YMCA is playing
that's how they dreamt up they'd go down
south and and Heinsohn used to adopt
them but an average should have them man
maybe we have three cigarettes and two
beers and half them and then then go
back out score 16 more a full court yeah
all right last one Bruins was you ever
go to a Bruins but I used to wait way
back yeah and and during the time when
or on that Krueger plan that if you were
not a Bruins fan in Boston you weren't
from Boston
right it was impossible then we became
friends with the cam the only stuff
later and and did you go see Bobby Orr
when he had the crew cut when he was
like super young Bobby yeah like oh he's
on the cover of Sports Illustrated yeah
like he's nine years old yeah like you
did when you first get on stage oh yeah
I look 97 years old that's so awesome
alright Don I love your brother
congratulations on the name of the
digital download is live with the
Manhattan available now on Sirius and
pant Pandora and then Friday everywhere
iTunes Spotify everything thank you so
much for coming on here this has been a
thrill [ __ ] it's ridiculous that I
finally got to shoot the [ __ ] with
because I always show up 10 minutes
before both gonna go on are you doing oh
yeah go [ __ ] yourself and then that
would be a site they finally got to talk
to you for like 45 to an hour mag
couldn't be happier but thanks so much
for helping me out here
alright no worries Don Gavin everybody
get the album live with the Manhattan
LegalZoom Oh wiggle some you know it's
easy to make the
to make the same old New Year's
resolutions that won't stick so why
don't you change it up this year use
LegalZoom to do something impactful in
your life make 2020 the year you
officially stat your business or you can
finally get your will in living trust
sorted out over the past 19 years
LegalZoom has helped more than 4 million
people they provide the resources you
need to confidently resolve your
personal and business legal needs you
can get started quickly online and if
you have any questions or need advice
they have the right people to help you
out Legal Zoom isn't a law firm so you
can count on their network of
independent attorneys for advice at the
right price since they don't change
charge by the hour make twenty twenty a
year you'll remember for the right
reasons and use Legal Zoom to help you
out go to legalzoom.com today and enter
the promo code brr-brr in the box at
checkout for special savings that's
legalzoom.com promo code bir LegalZoom
where life meets legal all right policy
genius everybody you know it's January
2020 the year 2020 shows up a lot in
science fiction a lot of people
predicted that by now we'd be
teleporting to work or living on Mars
and a lot of these those predictions
were wrong the truth is we'll always get
the future wrong which is why we need to
get life insurance right
that's where policy genius can help
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you could say
fifteen hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policy once you apply the
policy teams team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape which we all
know what that means because of my
podcast and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy they can also
help you find the right home insurance
and auto insurance or disability
insurance so if your science-fiction
dreams and for 2020s to levant become
science fact don't get discouraged get
life insurance it takes just a few
minutes to find your best price and
apply at policy genius comm policy
genius
we'll always get the future wrong but
get life insurance right hey what's
going on it's Bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday
January 23rd 2012 how the [ __ ] are you
how's it going let's get right down to
it this week all right
you know what I don't even get right
down to it what the [ __ ] am I talking
about what are you doing you know I can
take my time with this [ __ ] what do you
got to do you got to get back to work
shuffling your [ __ ] papers and your
cubicle is that what you got to do
readjust your paper clips they still got
paper clips out that way with all the
[ __ ] uh Steve Jobs [ __ ] that he
created you know something I watched all
kinds of football this past week weekend
obviously and he wanted the most [ __ ]
annoying thing why is everybody [ __ ]
on Steven Tyler going how bad was his
national anthem rendition all right guys
[ __ ] 63 years old he's singing
outside you know with no band behind him
right can we cut him some slack [ __ ] no
this is the Internet let's take this guy
down who's had more hit singles in all
of us who's gotten more [ __ ] than all
of us who women still want to bang
Jennifer Aniston like four five years
ago when she was still married to
[ __ ] baby blue eyes there you know
with his highlighted tips you know that
guy played Billy Beane Brad Pitt right
they had their list of five people that
they could bang one of hers was still
Steven Tyler I think one of Brad's was
Angelina Jolie oh I enjoyed that one did
you I don't give a [ __ ] so anyways he
sings the national anthem I thought he
did a great job I never [ __ ] problem
with it so anybody's this is what people
say on celebrity circuit they go Steven
Tyler how bad was his national anthem
rendition not do you think it was good
how did you like it
that just immediately staring it towards
the negativity which really is the
[ __ ] you know
bleeding baby seal of the Internet
everybody's gonna pile on they're all
gonna pile on and trash Steven Tyler why
because he stunk or because you hate
your [ __ ] life this is what this is
what how would how it is fellow American
Idol judges rate Steven Tyler's
rendition of the national anthem at the
AFC Championship game on Sunday let's
just say it probably wouldn't get him to
Hollywood he lives in a house in the
Hollywood Hills he's already there he's
a [ __ ] legend
he's in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
you know just when I think I'm the
biggest [ __ ] on the internet people like
this just blow right by me and just show
me a whole new level
a New England Patriots fan the 63 year
old American Aerosmith frontman warbled
the star-spangled banner before the New
England Patriots played the Baltimore
Ravens he missed the high note and
butchered some of the lyrics heckling
began before his performance ended you
know I got HGTV [ __ ] surround sound
when was that heckling I don't [ __ ]
get it
you mean when they cheered when he said
land of the free you know how bad was it
so let's listen to what all these people
have to say who can't even [ __ ] sing
this would be like me making fun of a
first-ballot Hall of Fame quarterback
saying he's overrated all right I'll
shut the [ __ ] up now dude it wasn't me I
didn't think was that bad oh my god what
was Steven Tyler wearing Jesus Christ
hang it up you know what he's a victim
up he's a victim of he still so [ __ ]
badass people think that he's they
forget that he's [ __ ] 63 years old
you know what I mean I don't know is it
because he's so badass or is it because
the Rolling Stones are still dragging
their asses out on the road cuz I've
noticed that with Aerosmith they never
got they never looked that [ __ ] old
because the Rolling Stones are always
going to be 10 years older than them so
I don't any of that make any [ __ ]
sense alright let's let's get back to
what the [ __ ] I wanted to talk about the
the football this week my [ __ ]
condolences to all
the Ravens fans out there except for
that fat [ __ ] from two years ago when
the Ravens won and made me never go to a
[ __ ] sports bar again to watch a game
remember that story the first play of
the game they handed the ball off to
[ __ ] Ray Rice and he ran 85 yards for
a touchdown and this guy just won he
just kept yelling you know I couldn't
win it when a professional player makes
an unbelievable play and they just start
yelling it's annoying enough when they
do it this guy was doing that looking
back now it's actually kind of funny
they was that much of a spaz and how mad
he made me he's the only Ravens fan that
I don't have sympathy for this morning
and I am not even gonna remotely talk
[ __ ] about that we basically we backed
into the Super Bowl you know that's not
one of those games you like yeah when it
came down to it what did we do we got in
your head and we [ __ ] threw some
salted butter over your shoulder or
whatever [ __ ] thing we could do to
make you miss a 32-yard field goal what
the [ __ ] I do gotta say I was surprised
at how well our defense played and you
know and I can't believe they didn't
review that [ __ ] touchdown the guy
caught the ball boom-boom both feet went
down right as the second one came down
more slapped it out of his hands and you
would have thought that they think you
know for a Super Bowl they would have
reviewed it for some [ __ ] reason they
didn't and [ __ ] 32-yard field goal
and the guy who did that poor bastard
that [ __ ] bastard
you know kickers always get made fun of
you know for being [ __ ] and that type
of thing do you know the balls it took
for that guy to walk into that locker
room after that with [ __ ] Ray Lewis
goddamn roided-out dragon breathing fire
sitting across from you I think if he
killed him I don't think anybody in
Baltimore but who would have [ __ ]
convicted him so I don't want to tell
you I can't talk any [ __ ] I'm excited
that my team is back in the Superbowl
but I'm also worried because I think the
Giants are [ __ ] world beaters there I
said it
alright I know I'm gonna get shipped
from
treats fans but be honest with you the
level of play in that Giants 49ers game
the level of hits that was a monster of
a [ __ ] game it really was and that
was one of those games was a shame that
anybody had to [ __ ] lose it so I
don't know I always have faith with
Belichick and his ability to come up
with a game plan but I don't know if
he's got enough guys to execute it
because I don't see a weakness in the
Giants corners are a little weak other
than that you know Tom cloth
Tom Coughlin to Bill Belichick I'm
saying that's a push at this point
Bella checks been around too long he's
like an old [ __ ] stripper everybody
knows his moves all right he's still up
there grinding on the pole to some
journey song you know so I think that's
a push running back she got to give it
to the Giants wide receivers that's a
push defensive front before no contest
that's the Giants linebackers I think I
linebackers been playing great but I
would say that slight edge to the Giants
in corners that's a flip and this is
gonna surprise you I would say at
quarterback I would say it's a push I
know I'll [ __ ] job-ready I don't give
a [ __ ]
Eli Manning plays his best when the
game's on the line the guy's one [ __ ]
five road playoff games since 2007 you
know so I'm not talking any [ __ ] and
it's not gonna surprise me if we lose no
but I'll surprise me if we win I think
it's gonna be another nail-biter
I hope although I do have a bad feeling
than in the second half it could get
ugly if if they have any sort of long
sustained Drive because they guy I'm not
good with the names whoever they're
[ __ ] fullback is who basically is
like he's like a defensive lineman but
he's a running back that [ __ ]
that guy can really wear down a defense
and I already had a nightmare of Brady
sitting on the sidelines wondering when
he was going to get the ball back so so
whatever look at the Patriots there's
7th trip to a [ __ ] Super Bowl with
three and three I'm hoping
gonna be four and three but like I said
49ers unbelievable [ __ ] game they
played and Raven fans I can't talk any
[ __ ] cuz I thought you got [ __ ] on
that that not them you should you you
deserved a replay on that play and you
know [ __ ] 32-yard field goal who's
kidding who thirty percent of people in
the crowd could have hit that you know
of Jesus what the [ __ ] does that how do
you sleep after you do something like
that like when I go on stage and bomb as
a comedian and I just let myself down
like I'm talking to myself I'm walking
around I come home I'm grumpy tunia I
act like an ass you know and I just let
myself down to let down [ __ ] what do
you want team forty-eight guys forty-six
whatever [ __ ] rule is to let down
40-plus other people who all are lifting
weights and can run a 440 and you're
walking in there built like you run the
[ __ ] math team I just the level of
balls and you're wearing those goddamn
stretchy pants that's the one thing I
got to give the Ravens [ __ ] for when did
you start wearing those ballet pants and
games I don't get it why are you guys
out there wearing those pantyhose is
there a giant remember those [ __ ]
eggs that pantyhose came in in in the
70s the [ __ ] were those things called
really dating myself is that what it's
about you know I Eddie Reid and [ __ ]
Ray Lewis that tough that they can
actually wear pantyhose and no one's
gonna give them [ __ ] I'll do it and the
safety in my own [ __ ] place 3000
goddamn miles away
I will [ __ ] do it but uh that's the
only [ __ ] I can give you other than that
man I thought you guys got you got
[ __ ] in the end so with that it is on
the Patriots are going against the best
quarterback in the Manning family you
understand me
it is Eli I just want to piss off cuz
I'm still gettin I'm still ki crit
please I'm still getting emails from
Peyton Manning fans
trying to tell me why the guy is better
than Tom Brady I get why can't we just
agree to disagree okay I get why you
think he's better than Tom Brady and
I'll never convince you otherwise
and I'll take Tom Brady let's just make
a truce leave it at that and how about
we enjoy what the [ __ ] Eli is doing
seriously it's a football fan it's
[ __ ] unbelievable you know it's
getting [ __ ] all over he's in the
toughest media market out there arguably
you know if it's not that as Boston or
Philly you know and any these guys going
out there when in the [ __ ] games
can't get mad at that alright but
whatever you do Peyton fans I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm not reading the emails
anymore because all you guys are doing
now is you're rewriting history and
you're coming back with your [ __ ]
excuses about well Peyton really never
had a defense acting like Peyton used to
lose to the Patriots 42:38 he didn't he
used to lose games 22:17 oh by the way
what did I say
Patriots 2320 think that's exactly what
happened you know and I was so confident
in that prediction that I didn't even
bet the game because I was like you know
what it's too easy no it's not true I
actually said twenty three twenty or
twenty-two seventeen and in the third
quarter I texted [ __ ] Paul virzi and
said this game's over we're gonna lose
because I thought our defense had broken
at that point so I'm not even gonna
[ __ ] you know whatever I hit a
half-court shot not looking but anyways
Eli oh wait a minute
Peyton stop [ __ ] trying to rewrite
history okay
he lost games like 22 17 that's how he
lost those [ __ ] games and it always
came down to the end and you always had
one more shot and he never got it done
alright that's all I'm saying so go [ __ ]
yourself and the [ __ ] Patriots
alright we had we had Antwon Jameson
old-ass Corey Dillon Tom Brady six round
draft pick by the way that people are
forgettin now cuz he's a superstar was
throwing the [ __ ] Deion Branch Troy
Brown and David Patten while [ __ ]
daddy long leg neck there was [ __ ]
throw into arguably the [ __ ] Jerry
Rice of the AFC had Marvin Harrison
Edgerrin James behind
behind them with his [ __ ] Sampson s
dreads right
he had all kinds of [ __ ] players his
defense was it the greatest no but it
was decent it was good enough to win a
game and you're ignoring the fact in his
Joe Montana moment in the Super Bowl he
threw a pick six to loose a superb all
right so go [ __ ] yourself go twist it
around all you want to twist it around
and ignore the fact that he can never
beat the [ __ ] Patriots and in that
one year he made like [ __ ] twenty
different clips where he felt it was a
penalty refs never called a flag because
it wasn't a penalty he took it to the
front office and they're like Payton we
don't know what to tell you it's legal
and then they were like well sure right
and then his owner who sits on the Rules
Committee changes the rules so now it is
illegal and guess what the next year he
beats the Patriots or two years later
whatever and gets his [ __ ] ring give
me a [ __ ] break you want to know why
all these guys are [ __ ] breaking Dan
Marino's records it's because of that
rule change it's [ __ ] ridiculous
these goddamn quarterbacks cornerbacks
if they even touch the [ __ ] receiver
they got a 50/50 chance of being called
for interference it's both the amount of
times I say that's [ __ ] [ __ ] and
the call goes my way it's [ __ ] I'm
not one of those [ __ ] sports fans who
think something's [ __ ] until it goes
against his own [ __ ] team I mean
until it until the call goes with my
team those [ __ ] rules are [ __ ]
I understand no hands to the face I get
that
five yards I get you know you can only
touch him after five yards but that [ __ ]
where the guy can't kind of have his
hand on you like hand check and yeah I
don't get that okay and he has to be
turning around looking at the ball to
[ __ ] put his hands up so he can't be
feeling back to see where the [ __ ]
you're at is it any wonder why these
guys are breaking Dan Marino's records
give me a [ __ ] break so [ __ ] all the
Peyton Manning fans the guy's a
first-ballot hall-of-famer I've always
told you that I just said in the
playoffs he's an easily frustrated guy
and his playoff record shows it he lost
to the eight and eight ninety seven
charges at home go [ __ ] yourself
back-to-back years I don't want to hear
it go blame that on your defense
all right there kunti the real man you
know what it is uh Peyton Manning is
Venus Williams and Elias Serena really
bill are you really I love how I said I
wasn't gonna talk about this but I'm
gonna continue talking about it
Peyton Manning is one of those guys that
the second he's retires I'm gonna
absolutely love him just like Magic
Johnson you know and I'm not solicit me
and I'm not [ __ ] bragging about the
Patriots cuz that's another thing going
them going to the [ __ ] Superbowl Ben
Roethlisberger was wearing one clown
shoe for the final third of this season
so we'd have to play the Steelers we
didn't have to play Peyton Manning and
the Colts we went up against touchdown
Jesus in their high school offense and
then we backed into the Super Bowl so I
am by no means confident all right but
you [ __ ] Peyton Manning fans go right
go rewrite history with each other okay
that's what you have to do because of
what happened so go [ __ ] yourself all
right I actually had somebody send me an
email go and see look look what the
Colts did this year that just shows that
Peyton Manning was consistently taking
making a five and 11 teen 13 and three
Marvin Harrison Edgerton James Marshall
[ __ ]
Dallas Clair all those guys right you
know the coaching the guy [ __ ] out
give me a break that was if that was a
five and 11 team so this team here is
the team he's had since 1998 are you
that [ __ ] stupid are you really that
[ __ ] stupid this year actually showed
not only how good Peyton was but also
how bad a franchise the [ __ ] Colts
are because they never took into
consideration that eat that knee light
that Peyton was ever gonna go down so
they had some guy from the [ __ ] YMCA
come in and back him up and yeah he lost
a bunch of [ __ ] games what if they
had Matt Cassell do you think they'd be
Owen [ __ ] 13 or whatever the hell
they were gone when they wouldn't you
know what are you gonna do why don't you
go change another rule why don't the
Colts go change another rule that if
your star quarterback goes down the
Colts automatically get 13 [ __ ] wins
it's not fair he hurt his neck all right
I know that whole [ __ ] rant was
annoying to a lot of people but you know
I really don't give a [ __ ] you know I
get [ __ ] on the internet just like
Stephen tire
I got one right here from my facebook
page bill I love your act but this thing
of publishing slash recording every
thought you have at a moment's notice is
seriously sad that's actually a
compliment that he said it was sad which
would mean that I've somehow dropped a
level you know I don't know if this guy
realized that I perform in strip malls
across the country so the fact that
anybody's even listening to this is a
major triumph and that's how I'm looking
at it all right I feel like I'm firing
on all cylinders I'm taking one game at
a time
anyways let's talk about I was in Texas
I wasn't [ __ ] Texas this weekend I
was in Houston then I was in Austin a
Tale of Two Cities
Austin is like hey buddy what the [ __ ]
you lookin at man right and then Austin
is like all the leaves are brown hey man
why don't we make a house out of hemp
man both of those stereotypes are gonna
are gonna [ __ ] annoy people but I got
to tell you I got one of the funniest
heckles I ever got when I was in Houston
I was at the House of Blues and thank
you to everybody who came up to my show
by the way to both shows I have [ __ ]
awesome time I was standing on stage and
I was talking about rappers getting
busted with the unregistered gun in the
car and I was like oh Jesus how many of
these guys have gotten busted for that
and this guy in the back goes it
immediately brought all his racial
tension into it and it was such a funny
vibe from the crowd afterwards I I
totally felt this vibe that like half of
them agreed and the other half were
cringing going you see this is why we
have this reputation it's not all of us
it's a select few it wasn't even half
the crowd agreeing with the guy but um
that's one of the things I love about
doing stand-up is those kinds of [ __ ]
moments like it remind me like a long
time ago
just one of those moments we just
realized that most people are decent
human beings because he meant of people
who [ __ ] cringed and then when I was
making fun of him afterwards we're like
almost like overly laughing just to a
show that listened we're not all like
that
like I'm have a long time ago I did this
this room in East Harlem in New York I
don't know what the [ __ ] it was it
looked like a lecture hall the way it
was set up with a stage was you know at
floor level and then the seats all went
up you know and I'm the only [ __ ]
white guy in there and there was some
woman there some and she was a drunk and
sort of like a neighbourhood legend so
she just kind of got away with doing
whatever she was she wanted to do she
was being rude and yelling out and kind
of making the show all about herself you
know one of those deals she thought she
was helping the show so I start giving a
[ __ ] I start [ __ ] on her - owner -
shut the [ __ ] up and all that blah blah
blah blah blah and the crowds laughing I
don't know she got upset or something
she stood up and I was like is she gonna
come onto the stage and she didn't she
started walking up the the aisles all
the way up to the top I mean in my head
I'm going thank God she left now I can
actually try and do my [ __ ] act here
so like about two minutes later I'm in
the middle of my act and I was imitating
something acting something out so I was
kind of leaning forward and one of my
legs was about six inches one of my feet
was like six six inches in front of the
other like standing like that almost
like a wide receiver lines up right and
all of a sudden I didn't realize this
that [ __ ] lady she took off her shoe
and [ __ ] like Kareem did a hook shot
and threw it down at me and it came in
and hit the inside of my leg almost hit
me in the balls and I don't know if
you've ever been on stage and someone's
thrown something that you you instantly
become absolutely [ __ ] livid alright
so she threw it at me it hit me and
immediately there was sort of this ugly
silence in the crowd because I don't
know cuz I was the only white guy there
she [ __ ] threw it just got really
weird and then also it was you know
somebody just threw something somebody
on stage it's like I was just gonna get
[ __ ] nuts right now so
I looked down at the shoe fortunately it
was one almost [ __ ] up looking shoes I
ever saw in my life it was just like
there was like glitter on it and duct
tape the [ __ ] thing was a mess so I
go uh I was like you know what I was
gonna get mad but upon looking at this
shoe I now realize this isn't about me
this is about her childhood and
everybody immediately started laughing
yada yada yada and I just remember at
the end of the show
the amount of people that came up to me
basically saying that they didn't
approve of what she did all nervous said
I was gonna then go down to the Lower
East Side in Manhattan and be those
people up in the [ __ ] East Harlem
McCray everybody was concerned that I
was gonna do that so it kind of took me
to that [ __ ] moment and I don't know
if you heard that shaken in the middle
of it my dog came in with the lovely Nia
who hasn't been on the podcast forever
you want to come on the podcast all
right well let me hit pause and I'll get
you a mic hang on a second
all right so anyways that was uh I don't
know can you tell I hit pause and I
don't even know where the [ __ ] I am
the lovely Nia everybody nice to be here
on a rainy Monday I gotta tell you that
leather is wacky out there w their show
biz foot yes lick is on and your rain
boots have you ever been to Houston did
you notice that there's no zoning laws
out there I did not notice that is one
of the ugliest cities I've ever been to
other than the downtown area it is just
an absolute [ __ ] in and I
understand now why people need to be in
power and why people have to be
controlled because if everybody just
does whatever the [ __ ] they could they
want to do just go to Houston they have
like they'll be like a strip mall next
to an old lady's house next to a
skyscraper they just have these
skyscrapers in the middle of nowhere hmm
it just you know like all these little
like you know a Tony's pizza just like
in New York every pizza is New York
Pizza I don't know why but everybody
claims to have it and then right next to
it will be this towering building
made all out of glass and and then next
to it will be just like an open lot yeah
it's it's it's one of the ugliest things
to be listening me we just yeah yeah
yeah speak into the mic please
no I was gonna say Boston doesn't do
that we have New York style pizza thing
but there is a place called New York
Pizza it's over by Emerson my and your
alma mater I was gonna say that Boston
doesn't do that we have New York style
pizza thing because Boston pizza is
amazing the bar pizza is amazing
what do you mean the bar pizza dude I
gotta say New York Pizza is really
overrated just because the amount of
people who [ __ ] ride on the coattails
of New York Pizza sure everybody cuz I
know my people go to New York oh dude I
went to eat the pizza it sucked it's
like yeah most of it does suck
because they have a reputation most of
the bagels suck well a lot of the [ __ ]
there sucks because they have to know
where to go yeah it's like Chicago style
pizza I went there and I was like this
stuff sucks it's like eating a big giant
piece of lasagna I don't like it and
then people go well where did you go and
I'm like I windows I went to Ed's Ed's
touristy place right next to the airport
that said authentic deep-dish Chicago
pizza yeah you gotta talk to the people
at the hotel or something well you know
it's funny about the people listen my
podcast I told these [ __ ] that I'm
trying not to drink on the road it's a
term of endearment
term of endearment it's not no but it is
you didn't see the twinkle in my eye
when I said it walking down the street
no I I would think that they would sort
of like blanket or I don't what not
blanket but a pillow or something like
we gotta get you set up better because
you just what I lay in the floor Ned you
look like a chiropractic nightmare like
a proper chair and a whole this lying on
the floor I can't I can't do it like I
can't [ __ ] do my podcast sitting down
why I don't know it feels too [ __ ]
professional I have to lay on the floor
but guys let me talk about Peyton
Manning who's a [ __ ] Hall of Famer
and could beat the [ __ ] out of me if he
flexed his neck
let me talk with [ __ ] about how to do it
in the bed in your underwear and now you
do it in a new place in a basement in
your sweat pants what were you talking
about pizza I don't know you go with it
now to consider when you wanted to take
in an entirely different direction you
want to talk about sexting and people
cheating no text messages that thing
this guy I would kill to read the
sexting between teenagers do they really
do they really know where anything is if
I had a sext when I was 14 I want to put
my hand where I think there's some stuff
I've never seen no you know what
actually with all this free porn they
probably know they know exactly what
it's probably like eighth grade he
didn't even know where my g-spot was
that's what it is now it's crazy people
it's [ __ ] great all right all right
all right I try to say it quickly don't
sit there and dwell on the actual
details that's what takes the funny out
of it when you actually really bring the
reality of it every night just talk
about fantasies some real [ __ ] know what
it is if you notice one of the reasons
why I talk so fast is you just it's like
running across the nice get right across
and that's anybody says anything you
just yell shut the [ __ ] up really loudly
in your mind my bully this is are you a
bully no talent here what do I do to you
around the house no you don't do what I
tell you what are you trying to get an
Oprah applause break why do all women
have to do that why do you have to come
on my podcast and you got to start
[ __ ] all over the place marking your
[ __ ] territory you shut your mouth
woman try to make me out bully me around
the house which is so not true so what
are you talking what don't I do what
don't I do that are exactly what I want
to do before you paint me you know
before you ruined my reputation let me
finish
I'm sorry maybe I shouldn't you know
break down the veneer that you have
projected of being like the man who
listened all those big words and she
wants to do when the reality is is quite
different and I'll just leave it at that
you see see what they do now there's a
classic female thing there they this is
what these broads do do you just set
they used all your big fancy words and
then you got a smart belt let me finish
and then you acted as though there was
gonna be this whole list of examples and
then the end you tried to sneak out the
back door gonna and I'm just gonna leave
it at that that's all I'm gonna say
about that and that would get you a
[ __ ] applause break on TV it would
yeah yeah you think that would hold up
in a court of law I know a lot of people
didn't think that that guy committed
this murder but let me just tell you I
know otherwise and I'm just gonna leave
it at that defense rests I mean
prosecution rests get the [ __ ] out of
here I was gone for [ __ ] three days
oh I can't lie I came home I came home
and I said I'm going over my buddy's
house to watch the football game that's
exactly how it went I'll be back and
cuddle you when I get home now Cleo has
to come over get out of here get out of
here with your [ __ ] paintbrush tummy
get over there lay down there's
scrumptious huh Oh
nervous Nellie over there oh my god
what's gonna happen man my last owner
was a jerk Cleo how long do we have to
be nice to you before you realize that
you're in heaven now how la do we saw
our dog is insecure our life coach slash
dog trainer brought that up so anyways
let's talk about get the [ __ ] dog out
of here don't beat it I'm just doing it
cuz I want people to be like you're so
mean to that dog and they don't realize
that I lay down and spoon with her more
than I do with you is obsessed with this
dog No obsessed
just imagine have a love affair if you
had a friend who was always happy to see
you
and was covered in fur you what you
wouldn't want to give that person a hug
every once in a while my problem is is I
go to the dogs energy when that dog gets
amped up I take it to the next level and
next thing you know I'm already
predicting I'm gonna lose a front teeth
tooth to her [ __ ] head that would be
hilarious I'm sure you'd like that
sexting sexting alright this isn't
really well this is about this guy he
remember I told you that story about
that dude he worked for some corporation
see a cubicles alright and then I'm sure
he's on some sort of team right anybody
has to do some sort of song before they
go in there like those poor kids and
we're out building exercises yeah
because people who work at the Cold
Stone Creamery you ever see them like
with like making like the goddamn ice
cream going hi-ho hi-ho it's off to work
I just that that like the part of me
dies when I see that when I just see
people like it's like basically watching
someone working like an ice cream death
camp none of them are happy
none of them dreamed of doing that maybe
if you're like a fatty you know when you
got a job in an ice cream store kind of
like a pedophile getting a job at like a
Cub Scout camp Wow you know isn't that
what they always end up I love working
with kids you know I said that last week
follow your dreams unless you're a
pedophile Yeah right
so I Siddhant using that I shouldn't say
that I have a problem with fatties
working in the ice cream store let's
let's let's get to this [ __ ] so anyways
so they're gonna get everybody in shape
so they hire some sort of personal
trainer and he's training everybody
alright and what he does is he gets
everybody's emails great move on this
guy's part [ __ ] great move now he
doesn't have to deal with him face to
face and if there's any [ __ ] hotties
he wants to bang he can take it to the
next level
perfect yeah that's how you do it okay
shooting fish in a [ __ ] barrel
efficient barrels and in a shooting
gallery so anyways so that the office on
this guy notices that well you know he
gets one text
going hey Brad you know just do a couple
more jumping jacks and you should be
fine for some reason his little haughty
wife has to get like 40 [ __ ] texts
from this guy at like 11:30 at night oh
I do remember this yeah yeah the same
place right so he [ __ ] he finds out
about he can't asking his wife I
remember this okay I'm gonna recap for
people he last week all right so he
keeps asking his well he's catching his
wife late at night texting going and he
goes who are you texting
and she would immediately slam the phone
shut cuz she's got a flip phone
evidently and would say no button really
would say nobody would get mad and say
nobody right so this guy's not a [ __ ]
he figures out something's up sure he's
in he's into some sort of [ __ ]
Spygate [ __ ] where he's at he hacks into
her thing gets her password and sees
that all these text messages back and
forth to Trainor so what is he doing
he's a goddamn man does he slap his
[ __ ] wife around no he goes right to
the trainer and says hey sport no cuz
you get sued you get sued for that now
you get sued for kicking somebody's ass
when you're right yeah um you go he goes
hey sport once you do me a favor and
stop texting my [ __ ] wife in all
hours of the night
so then sporto there immediately starts
acting like a [ __ ] around him starts
acting overly nice well you know what
all guilty people do right he's innocent
he would have got mad sure be like dude
what the [ __ ] you talking about
I always text people about how to get
make their core stronger at 2:00 in the
morning I'm dedicated maybe you should
be inspired by what I'm doing I
specifically am interested in women
having a strong core because they're so
beaten down in society you know he would
have come back with some [ __ ] like that
but he didn't now he's all like hey man
how are you with this hoe please don't
beat the [ __ ] out of me or ain't exposed
me for being the dirtbag I am so I lose
this giant money-making client here
right
so anyways she denies the whole [ __ ]
thing so he sent a couple of actually a
couple of texts that this girl wrote
they were talking about the Beatles and
he writes all those damn Beatles songs
make my stomach hurt when I listen to
them because it reminds me of getting
ready to go see you they give me anxiety
this is what the trainer is writing to
this guy's
why not what sort of exercise are they
talking about there is that uh was that
push-ups so then she writes back all the
lonely people where do they all belong
oh right and then he said I remember you
asking me if I related to that song if I
related that song to you because I
thought you were lonely it's talking
about a [ __ ] marriage yeah oh this
guy this guy's a dirtbag yeah oh this
guy he's just saying everything we
talked about music yeah my feeling right
and what it is his dick is is is
downloading all the knowledge in this
guy's brain that he has about human
beings and he's just given her and the
dick is just is basically sitting in the
Captain Kirk chair he's just [ __ ]
anything she wants to hear so anyways
then he write another one he said I know
[ __ ] my life I wear my [ __ ] my life to
sleep and I have a confession to make I
also wear your panties she goes LOL shut
up he writes it's true so I don't know
what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy's
into but the real question is not
whether or not that that's socially
acceptable the real question is how did
he get this married woman's panties he
at least finger blaster would you go
with me on that I mean if he's just
saying that's be just like controversial
that's what I thought but she goes lol
shut up he goes it's true yeah we talked
about the mic oh he made it so be joking
around but if you're just wearing but if
he is she gave it to him how else would
he have him and they're talking about
the Beatles if it's true okay so that's
face what I'm saying so okay [ __ ]
he's got a [ __ ] panties they're both
adults I'm guessing by this she's like
in her 30s what is he doing fingering
her and taking around for a malt he's
banging her [ __ ]
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] could be a
great movie kids a great character for a
[ __ ] movie um so anyways he's sitting
that's what he said his wife she still
Dennis denying this whole conversation
ever happened she's just in complete
obviously denial she's in denial he said
I'm dumping her not for the reminiscing
talk but fun but for lying to me he's
not interested in trying to please say
that Nia and I swear to God on the
throne computer are you [ __ ] he's not
interested in what I don't know working
it out no no I'm not gonna leave you
with dead silence go ahead tell me oh no
no no no I just I don't know no he's
right
I would just pose me a question that's
all well within is right I don't
understand why she it doesn't just fess
up then that's a whole nother topic is
the hunger the topic I mean no you know
what is missing no I feel like part of
the story is missing or something what
the video of them [ __ ] is that what's
missing what else Mia if you start
blaming him for not paying attention and
that's why she's [ __ ] this guy I will
I will [ __ ] throw you out of this
room I'm just saying so he says to her
are you cheating on it you [ __ ] this
guy and she's like no shut up what are
you talking about like and she just
flat-out denied I don't understand how
she can flat out deny something is hot
she's a piece of [ __ ] that's why I'm so
she's a lying piece of [ __ ] on Nia yeah
but if you have something and you're
like looking at it like this is what you
wrote how are you denying it
because because she just just didn't
that's what denial is you're totally in
denial I don't know the frickin problem
is you [ __ ] drinking on nyquil I
think it tastes good I don't have a
problem right yeah I like sleeping you
know yeah you know what it is I'm just
making sure you keep speaking of the mic
this is what you keep that
I want people here what do you have to
say okay all right all right but this is
good [ __ ] and I'm ruining it no my
[ __ ] Lord you know it kills me and
she was still like it's just I don't
know I'm gonna piss you off right now
you ladies will do things you guys
defend each other like right there and
like I did that I am NOT defending her
well let me can I get up my what I'm
gonna say if a guy did that [ __ ] you be
like dump his ass girl he's a [ __ ]
loser you can do better than that call
me will lead a little moon pie I'll
build you up that's what the [ __ ] you
would have done but because yeah I just
feel like some part of the story is
mythic what is missing I guess nothing
Thank You Nia thank you for being on the
podcast a good [ __ ] 20 minutes mmm
yeah that agree with me agree with the
decision this guy made this isn't about
me Nia please okay I'm just a messenger
here sure you know I'm just trying to do
all right here's the deal
man a woman if the person you're with is
texting past I would even for regular
people who aren't in show business the
booty hour starts after 11:00 I would
say after 11:00 yeah okay but that's but
that's what somebody you're already
[ __ ] okay I know you don't understand
it cuz you don't have to talk yourself
into a guys we have to spend the plates
the second we meet are all the way
through so you got to be setting it up
okay you know 7:30 is too creepy and
stalkerish and I would say you start
going past 9:30 she's gonna feel like
like you just she's some sort of [ __ ]
if you haven't [ __ ] her yet right so
you got you guys that this is that
window uh-huh about 8:15 to about 907
you have to do the setup text okay in
the setup text is not talking about
[ __ ]
it's go oh you know I'm watching blah
blah blah on TV so-and-so is so
ridiculous I'm sort of [ __ ] just to
get it going you don't I mean right yeah
like a boxer you feel him out in the
first round or the Beatles yeah
load it up right you're feeling it up
yeah that's what they're doing right
this [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] this this guy yeah you know
something as much of a piece of [ __ ] is
that that guy is if he writes a book I
would read it in a second why because
you know he's got great I mean the
position he has that's like when I used
to take I used to take that that yoga
class when I was out here and there was
that guy out in Santa Monica and he was
a phenomenal [ __ ] teacher right and
this place was jam-packed and it was by
donation only so then for tax purposes I
think he falls under a church I know it
helped him with taxes and it's all in
cash mm-hmm so it's all good all right
and then two hottest [ __ ] women some
of the hottest women ever move out to LA
to become actresses okay he's got him in
his class getting off getting them all
stretched out before he bangs him it was
one of the greatest it was it was
[ __ ] airtight yeah and he would go
around the class and somehow me having
never touched my toes since I was in the
womb was somehow always doing every
position correctly yet all these other
hotties always needed to be adjusted
Yeah right around the psoas so I don't
get mad at a guy who's got a good thing
but you you know stay away from the
[ __ ] married ladies yes anyways isn't
that right Cleo here we go I bought the
wrong dog for dog food look how fat
she's getting a new feed of this diet
stuff she looks like a prize-winning Pig
right now yeah the brothers would be
saying what's up to we're number one hey
here's advice for the week all right hey
Bill I'm 20 I'm a 21 year old guy who
still lives with his parents that's not
bad
in this economy that's totally
acceptable I have unless you're sitting
at home and you're jerking off to porn
and maxing out your credit cards and
that's a dumb thing to do hey you know
what no porn for this year I I have yet
to watch porno this year well I'm still
early and that support does that support
everybody why do you need me to support
you not watching porn I don't have a
problem if you watch porn you know what
somebody sent me an article I got hit
again cuz I'm gonna uh I'm gonna find
this somebody's sent me an article about
help watching too much online porn how
it's not healthy for you and could
actually add to deport to depression if
I can say that word I feel like it
probably gives you like a higher
expectation of what your sex life should
be but you know because we're back to
what you feel should be going on in your
life in a moment I feel like he should
be able to pick me up over his over his
head and turn me upside down and do
things to me with my back problems in a
second you know what sorry to say I
can't find that [ __ ] email that dude
sent me and all I found was a bunch of
people trashing that online porn is not
addictive yeah it's one of those deals
nion why don't you put the microphone
over your shoulder you loosen it playing
with you sorry you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna [ __ ] homina homina I'm
gonna get a desk down here with two
[ __ ] chairs so the mic will be you
know yeah right there okay okay all
right
we will work on it okay all right I feel
like you have something to contribute
and I just don't feel like people are
hearing you see how I did that people
like complimented I stroked her ego so
she can do thank you
I just want people to know that I'm here
I have not watched porn this whole like
some time at the end of December I
watched something and it was so
disgusting that when I was done I
actually burst it out laughing as if I
just watched bridesmaids it's just and I
was just like what is wrong with me like
I actually got to that point in porn
where the porn was so [ __ ] up it was
just funny to me not that the people
were doing it this there was just
something pathetic and I was like can I
gotta walk away from this hey last year
I didn't drink this year I'm swearing
off the porn okay see that all right I'm
always trying to become a better person
here and what do you do
constantly [ __ ] all over me by the way
you got a couple of shout outs in
Houston oh did I
yep when I brought out the podcast yes
you know I was with a wonderful lady was
that people yelled Nia
and then one of your friends texted you
and said yo you got a couple of shout
outs so then when you brought it up in
the car I was like you were like what
does that mean what does that mean I got
like shout out like you don't know what
a shout-out is I didn't yeah you did you
wanted to hear what people said what is
a team a were they chanting my name it's
gonna be the end of us near when people
start liking you more than me and then
we're gonna break up like Sonny and Cher
but still perform together for a little
bit if we break up your fans are going
to hate me I just know it already
because they because they're already
gonna be on your side they're just gonna
be second fiddle Marshall Marshall
Marshall blame them all right number one
numero uno I'll order hey Bill I'm a 21
year old guy who still lives with his
parents I have a history of being very
introverted oh my god if you start
saying that you torture small animals
I'm gonna stop reading this I've been
that way ever since I was in junior high
well what were you in elementary school
were you going all out no cuz I would i
would have related to that I'm in
college now and I've become more social
at least when I'm on campus and at my
job but I'm having a really hard time
building a life for myself outside of
those arenas did I write this to myself
20 years ago I totally relate to this
guy I don't really have much of a life
I'm really bored most of the time and I
feel like I'm wasting my youth all right
I know that I have to go out more and
hang out with my friends it's up to me
to take some kind of initiative clio for
[ __ ] sakes get out of my face and if it
was up to me I would I totally would I
live with my parents though and that's
why it's kind of tricky my parents are
very into the Lord oh gee I don't really
share their beliefs good for you and so
when I want to go out the evening
usually includes a variety of activities
that my parents would give me a hard
time about normal stuff such as drinking
a little weed man and secretion of the
semen okay drink
you're smoking weed you're getting laid
what's the problem the problem is you
live with your parents no it does he
want to do that and he doesn't are you
saying no he's saying he goes out he
does his [ __ ] and his parents took him a
hard time so he's doing this suit maybe
he's getting guilt why don't I read the
rest of it I know that I'm a young adult
and I'm old enough to make my own
decisions a lot of my own decisions he
says I just don't have the strength of
character to look my parents in the eye
and have a discussion about all this
stuff with them I especially had the
problem with my mom she was raised
religious and has very different idea
about being 21 than I do I just don't
feel like she would understand if I
tried to have a conversation with her
about my thoughts I wish I could just
come and go as I please without being
bothered I have a car but I can't avoid
the questions about where I've been I
know that my personal life is my
business and I don't share all of it but
they don't seem to understand then top
all this I'm gonna go to church every
week and I will rather [ __ ] my own ass
then go to one more church service all
right do you yeah you got to move out
yeah you got to move out sput the end I
feel trapped I want to move out there it
is but I have no money and doing my job
selling burgers isn't going to pay the
rent in any place I know I'm not sure
what to do please for the love of God
rescue me oh Jesus rescue yourself
yes rescue yourself you got it what
you're 21 you're still working your way
through college right yeah you got it
you've got to get on a track where
you're gonna get some sort of better
paying job once you take some student
loans take out some student loans you
know which is a bad [ __ ] idea cuz
then you'll be even further in debt I
don't have anything well you know what
though he's probably not living on
campus because maybe his parents can't
afford it so that's why he's living at
home they can't afford that part of the
educator that or they don't believe that
they should live there because of all
the sinners he'd be with devil is in
that another job you got a roommate
situation save up your money get a car
with a bench seat do all your [ __ ] in
there and then come home and just always
have library books that you walk it in
with and just live a lie yeah until you
have the money to move on you don't have
to
yeah you talk to your parents about
anything in particular unless they're
doing something that's really abusive to
you or something you don't have to talk
to them about your life it's your life
yeah try sarcasm what'd you do tonight
smoke crack and got a hooker good night
mom and she'll be praying the rest of
the night she'll leave you alone no but
you got to make some sacrifices so you
can save some money get an apartment
with a roommate and live your own life
beef burgers though how can he do that
this is like a guy neiha who's on the
verge of selling drugs isn't that what
they always say what do i do sell
burgers I need to make some money well I
don't know yeah I know his ghetto is his
ghetto was his parents house yeah ask
for a raise you got to figure it out but
I think you're also becoming a little
bit complacent because you don't have to
pay bills and your parents buy your food
for you and all that other stuff so I
think there might be yeah get a car with
a vacation on your part to really fully
leave get a car with a bench seat that's
all I'm saying what is it bench seat in
a car what is a bench seat it doesn't
have like the little console it's not
bucket seats those ones back in the day
you know yeah you could [ __ ] cars
yeah yeah I think you didn't that you
could never do that now mm-hmm
yeah the bench seat like my my truck has
your truck no I didn't I bought an old
Ford truck and oh gee yeah let's get a
360 v8 shifts three on the tree and I'm
getting some new headers put on it
because you could like my breath on fire
yeah I would drive it like Ace Ventura
down the street because everybody kept
telling you know your headers look fine
I'm like dude I'm telling you you could
light my breath on fire if I drive this
thing for forty five [ __ ] minutes
because they would drive around the
block and be like dude it's fine and you
couldn't see anything really come at
least are untrained eyes so I get it
back today yes you do getting back to
getting back to this whole scenario here
you need to stop having your little pity
party there and pick yourself up by your
bootstraps get your [ __ ] together no
more of this I'm awkward I don't have
and I don't understand that it start
reaching out to some people figure out
what to do about a job save your pennies
get a car with a bench seat and do what
you want to do and move your ass out
figure it out start talking to people
maybe someone's looking for a roommate
and they're like hey you know only if a
couple hundred bucks I'll let you sleep
on my couch [ __ ]
you know all right number two all right
dear bill I need some advice I'm thirty
years old and I've been seeing this for
the past four months and things have
been getting I've gotten pretty serious
I'm already having dinner at her parents
house frequently Oh Gigi's going to her
family party though spending the
holidays together Jesus Christ
I'm practically part of the family I
read ready to use her father's words and
to be honest I'm cool with it
I love this girl she's great all right
so what's the problem so so great in
fact we decided to do New York New
Year's in Palm Beach together at her
cousin's place and now he finally writes
oh Jesus all right know what's gonna
happen see I'd like some of these these
these letters though they set him up
like a great movie like he set this up
like this is perfect this is like a
Norman Rockwell parent yeah the paint
painting everything's going great now
all of a sudden he's going to New Year's
and Palm Beach together at a cousin's
place what why what could possibly go
wrong this is very well-written this guy
gets a star anyway so we go out the
night before New Year's there's a whole
group of us and I head off to take a
piss I come back and see my girl dancing
and making out with some other guy who
wasn't a member of our group oh well who
gives a [ __ ] if he was a member of the
group it's another guy I'm obviously
flummoxed this educated son of a [ __ ] I
decided to interrupt their little
makeout session on the dance floor it
would have continued unabated if I
hadn't stepped in so I pushed the guy
aside hand her back her purse yes I was
carrying her purse for her it fit into
my back pocket
case you're wondering I was wondering
and I leave the bar the bar is called
the cocina ya kitchen right right I
think so yeah I am a little Spanish
right there I am outside just beside
myself with anger and she doesn't follow
me out I go back to her cousin's place
and go to bed around 3:00 a.m. the texts
come in nothing happened I didn't do
anything
she finally cops to it and just in her
defense she says I'm just not used to
having a boyfriend and I don't think you
know how drunk I was so happy new years
no no no no no when she when she showed
up to him she says fine just said look
she paid yeah fine I [ __ ] the guy I'm
just not used to having a boyfriend okay
and I don't think you realize how drunk
I was Wow yes see and you can be that
honest you know what I mean I could
never be that honest with you because
you could throw a vase at me and then
the cops would arrest me for breaking
the vase with my forehead anyways he go
he goes
should I chalk this up to a dumb drunk
mistake and patch things up I've been
hey I'm having trouble being objective
about this this has really got me [ __ ]
up and hurting yeah dude yeah that was
that was a ridiculous level of acting
out that's crazy
that is absolutely no made out with a
guy right in front of you he knows what
he knows he knows we suppose he's
[ __ ] stunned yeah yeah Jesus Christ
that's pretty stunning we're wearing the
goddamn trauma unit right now and you're
going you stepped on a landmine yeah
move on yeah that is retain some dignity
and yes and we basically just imagine if
you discovered that 17 years in married
with four kids that half look like you
and half look like this should have been
stripper
all right um you dodged a bullet and
yeah it's gonna hurt and that's really
what that really is dude is aside from
your feelings that's your [ __ ]
manhood being hurt right there is a guy
that shit's not supposed to happen right
because you're supposed to put it on
them and they're supposed to be
mesmerized by your dick and the reality
is is that's not what it's like and when
you discover that that's that's a tough
day never trust those broads again you
never trust him again that's the safest
place you can be no number three but
don't look at the glass shattered with a
shitty horrible thing that happened and
you should be feeling all those feelings
including anger so but just walk away
it's what you do is just walk away
although I would be tempted to pull a
female move and get some revenge and I
would tell her dad you know what do you
know what you know what a [ __ ] you're in
love with that's half your DNA did she
get that from your [ __ ] wife not an
[ __ ] he'll understand why she did it
I'm trying to inflict the most pain here
I walk away I don't do revenge don't do
that [ __ ] all right number three less
sad let's say say as they say in Boston
one over [ __ ] say there's no
consonants in that word there's D Friday
I always do that with Previn say unless
say how was that with my friends
and I was shit-faced we were at a bar
and I was sitting at a table when I saw
the girl saw the girl she was absolutely
beautiful I don't know why but something
told me I had to go up to that girl see
they don't we start [ __ ] phenomenally
Sun was out Jesus was walking on the
clouds she saw me looking at her and I
get her oh and I give her a wink when
she smiled at me Jesus he went with that
did you give her the double point too um
I then tried then turned to my friends
and said loudly give me a [ __ ] pen
oh Jesus is he drunk give me a [ __ ]
pen
they gave me a pen and I wrote my number
on a napkin and went over to her and her
friend I slapped in wearing a scarf -
this guy's like the most interesting man
in the world I love him he's wrestling a
badger in the corner hang on a second
give me a pen he goes I slapped the
napkin on the table and went to her went
to her ear and said I don't drink often
but I think you are [ __ ] beautiful
and walked away what
no he's hammered this is [ __ ]
hilarious I totally missed the joke in
this this guy is completely [ __ ]
hammered right he's sitting there head
Bob change your life sweetheart I love
this guy so anyways being shit-faced I
didn't know any better and I guess I
went to the table and put my head what I
went to the table and put my head was
down at that point according to my
friends she wanted to know what my name
was and stuff so my friends went over
and talked to her and talked me up
before she left she came up to me this
guy's still in the game here and told me
her and her friends were leaving to go
to a different bar I asked her name we
talked a little bit and she left with
their friends I told her please text me
three four days passed and I hadn't
heard anything I couldn't get her out of
my head she was seriously the most
beautiful girl I had ever seen
yeah after drinking a 12-pound gemstone
and there was something about her I know
I was shit-faced but I have never felt
that way I looked I looked online for
her on Facebook the other person she was
with had gone to high school with we
weren't friends but we knew each other I
found the girl on her friend list there
we go I know that is creepy but I want
to message her and tell her I am sorry
for being so drunk but I really want to
talk to her I feel she wouldn't have
come up to me before she left and my
friends and asked my friends my name if
she wasn't somehow somewhat intrigued I
don't think that's creepy
then nowadays in the old school when I
grew up that's not creepy and I think if
you just say listen
sorry I was so drunk the other night I
really meant what I said and I'm sure
this freaks you out that I don't even
say freaking out like they're not trying
to invade your privacy I just wanted to
say I meant those things that I said
yeah respectfully yours here's my phone
number my address and just leave it at
that I'll leave it at that there you go
no more communication after that because
then you're venturing into weird - what
time we got on the podcast all right all
right well we're getting close to the
end here we got over eight and
underrated with that also I want to
remind everybody that Amazon thing's
been working out for me it's a good
thing so I don't have to charge for the
podcast so this is basically I'm telling
people if you're gonna buy something on
Amazon rather than going directly to
Amazon amazon.com go to the go to
billboard comm click on podcast and on
the right hand side you'll see just
under the iTunes link you'll see the
Amazon window and you just click on that
and I will get credit for driving
traffic to amazon.com you don't have to
hit anything else after that and I'm not
telling you to buy anything I'm just
saying if you gonna and you're gonna go
to Amazon just please go to
billboard.com first even if it's on the
house
I'm just gonna browse for something I
don't know if it works that way yeah
they gotta spend some money oh they do
yeah it's like I'm driving driving
people to a drug dealer he's just gonna
look at the cocaine sniff it for a
second and then nothing they need to
make their money even if you just get a
browse if you just want to see what
they're doing with their website yeah
that's it it's a great way to donate to
the podcast like I said 10% of all
donations will then go on to the Wounded
Warriors Project so you support this
podcast you support the troops America
America that's right bye [ __ ] you donate
sport the troops
it's alright they're a couple of clicks
of the mouse so there you go overrated
underrated for this week underrated the
feeling of knowing you're you're leaving
a job and ceasing to give a flying [ __ ]
Aroo from the time you are offered
another job until the time you put in
your two weeks notice and finally
through those last two weeks and finally
going through those last two weeks
hear me out this
is an amazing feeling for some reason I
got a feeling he's not gonna leave like
the way the Patriots the way Drew
Bledsoe left the Patriots where he was a
total class act and should have been
co-mvp a super bowl xxxvi all right here
we go
I was offered a better paying job last
week at another company but have yet to
give oh well this guy already got
offered a better job by another company
he's yet to give his two weeks notice at
his current job because I am do my
yearly bonus this coming Tuesday I don't
want to jeopardize my current company
not paying the bonus so I'm holding out
until this coming Wednesday to give my
two weeks after I collect the bonus so
they can't take it back oh that's a
little dirty that's a little dirty no no
it's good but that's one of them I mean
what he's getting compared to the people
at the top are getting is is is it's
probably you can't even compare it so
yeah but the people with don't you guys
know gave him a [ __ ] job that's
that's one of those things like you're
dating somebody and then you find who
you really want to be with so you
[ __ ] propose to them you got the
wedding all set and as the invitation
goes out you go oh by the way that this
is over and I'm on now no I know it's
somewhere in there you go into their
piggy bank and take money well look I
understand what he's doing but that's a
yeah that's one of those things where
because you don't know how this next
jobs gonna go so this next job doesn't
go well and then he needs the
recommendation of these last people
they're gonna knock it down if you mean
that [ __ ] guy about that he's leaving
this place a little on bad terms yeah
for sure yeah he's gone Albert
Haynesworth here rather than through
brother drew blood stuff that's all I'm
saying yes overrated
overrated cookies what unless they're
straight out of the oven
oh they're dry and everyone wants to
make oatmeal cookies at some point you
know what that's funny I actually had in
my dressing room Nene did I mention I'm
in show business they had a plate of
cookies and you know me I got a sweet
tooth right yeah because I'm half of
they had this plate of cookies and I ate
the first one it was it was terrible
mm-hmm dico but knowing you you kept
eating them cookies and there was four
different kinds of Mike what are the
odds there's gonna be two different
flavors of cookies and they're both
gonna be bad god they're so funny about
that it wasn't yeah ridiculous the
[ __ ] jim-dandy going and keep matter
I would eat at Jim Danny's with a group
of old ladies every day at Friendly's if
they would have me that's for the older
guys he used to go to friendlies I know
friendlies yeah but do you know the Jim
Dandy no the Jim Dandy came in and
[ __ ] glass like those old light beer
from Miller commercials where it was
basically go let me get a glass of beer
and they basically with pouring like a
at least two beers into the thing mm-hmm
just imagine a goblet I believe it's
called friendlies served alcohol no I'm
talking about the vase that they would
stick this Sunday and oh I think I would
know know who was I with I was working
with somebody recently and we went into
if I would stop at Friendly's when when
I'm back is D'Angelo's all the places I
ate when I was a kid so I [ __ ] went
in there and I was laughing because I
saw they still had the Jim Dandy and I
just read the ingredients okay I just
read my dog has her head of my stomach I
[ __ ] read the ingredients and it was
it was the most ridiculous thing it was
like three different kinds of ice cream
like full scoops awful [ __ ] banana
you know like half a bottle it was
disgusting yeah it was like doing a keg
stand with like ice cream and trying to
set the fraternity record anyways I'm
trying to say I have a sweet tooth and
this [ __ ] dog is distracting me Cleo
I want you to know we're wrestling after
this we're going round and [ __ ] round
all right underrated this is the last
thing animatronics puppets makeup etc I
remember the days when the cool scary
monster was handmade by extremely
talented artists and technicians not
software these creations appear much
more believable and frightening over the
comparative comparatively lazy see
lazy CGI stuff like alien the thing
Hellraiser poltergeist jaws and
countless other examples are gent all
genuinely freaked me out growing up I
mean what compares to jaws these days
shark Night 3d [ __ ] get real [ __ ]
get real man alright that's my guess I
know what he's saying but he's writing
but also school versus yeah they don't
make them like they used to etc yeah one
of my favorite shots is that slow-motion
one of that crazy lady who's on the ice
skates with the [ __ ] hatchet you ever
see that what are you talking about I've
talked about this my podcast before
there was some horror movie I watched on
like Showtime or Cinemax a long time ago
and at like 2:00 in the morning I'm
watching this and this lady first lady
was skating on a pond and all of a
sudden they just start showing the
skates of this murderer this [ __ ] up
mask in this long hair was skating in
slow motion and then just [ __ ] put
his hands up and had like a tomahawk oh
yeah somebody find that horror film and
yes a clip from YouTube or something
I'll get it I'll try it I'll try and get
it up I'll look up on YouTube
psycho [ __ ] [ __ ] ice skates hatchet
searched all right that's the podcast
for this week please go to amazon.com
through my website bill bird comm click
on the podcast click on Amazon go buy
yourself some [ __ ] you don't need help
me out and help out more importantly 10%
going to the Wounded Warriors Project
that's the that's the podcast for this
week hey everybody how about that NFL
Pro Bowl that they now [ __ ] up by
sticking in between the championship
games in the Super Bowl so no one who's
in this Super Bowl actually plays we're
going to that next year we're going to
the Pro Bowl we are wait you don't like
sports I'm going Hawaii by myself that's
it everybody have a great time go [ __ ]
yourselves don't take any [ __ ] I'll talk
to you next week
you